hi I'm with Kasich here's a co-founder
of Lockett and you're actually one of
the cofounders with you know who I spoke
to earlier right yeah and could you talk
to me a little bit about the design
process and sort of how you go about
testing with users and how do you make
sure that you're building the right
things for your users
well our product is mainly a lock screen
product so we have to be very very
careful what kind of things we put on
lock screen what colors we choose what
kind of things we are actually modifying
or like notifying on the lock screen
because this screen is seen by user like
almost 100 250 times a day so it's very
very near to the user and he has to make
sure that he really likes that screen
and it's non intrusive so we take care
of things like very simple design we
also make sure that he can quickly
access what he wants to access and we
also keep things like timers and like
weather icons on the lock screen in
right places so that he can very
naturally go look at that instead of
actually searching for it and the color
of the ring on the lock screen is also
very carefully chosen because we don't
want to make sure we want to make sure
he does not find it very intrusive or
like taking away his space or he doesn't
like it or all those things are taken
into consideration fonts and styles are
also taken care over there but apart
from that because the lock screen is
something which you look at when you
first go into your phone there are
places where you wouldn't want your
neighbors to look at what is on your
lock screen and all these things so
taking care of that as well is a very
important thing we all these things put
together make the design process at lock
at a little more complex than any other
place but however we a be test all the
features and make sure we pick up right
things and that how that's how the
design process goes at lock